cubs getting set to host the pirates the
first of a three-game series here at
wrigley field udarvish going for the
cubs he allowed three runs on six hits
in four innings in a loss saturday to
milwaukee in his career though against
pittsburgh darvish has made five starts
he's one and two an era of three
darvish to adam frazier
that is ball four
and the dreaded lead off walk newman
likes hitting in this ballpark garvish
close at first on a pick-off attempt
indeed very close at first
cubs are contemplating a challenge
they're going to go ahead and challenge
this
first inning challenge would lead you to
believe they uh pretty conclusive
evidence that he nabbed him
oh boy you better be ready
because if he's out
i know what you're gonna say
i'll let you sir
down goes frasier
frazier has a look of a bottom of a guy
who knows he's been nabbed we'll see
[Music]
two down and bell will bat with the
bases clear but
bill hits this one on a hop to the
shortstop baez over on the other side
pirates will send trevor williams to the
mound tonight trevor we'll look to go a
little deeper in the ball game i thought
he pitched pretty well through one away
anthony rizzo the batter here's the
pitch and the swing of the man struck
him out fastball over the heart of the
plate but that kind of jammed him colin
moran leads off
the second inning for the pirates
against you darvish
it's this hard to right and moran
with a solid single to right field will
bring up brian reynolds
and he swings and misses for the first
out
garvish gets his first strikeout 96 with
attitude gregory polanco was held to
just 42 games
last year
back-to-back case
for darvish three infielders now on the
right side of second against jason
hayward
that'll be the first cubs hit a liner in
the center for hayward two out single
for hayward and now it's victor caratini
the catcher
caratini with a little floater and it's
in
hayward will
[Music]
just get back in safely so a little
two-out rally here and now jason kipnis
has an rbi
opportunity a swing and a miss breaking
ball down and in puts away kipnis to end
the innings bryant lined out
to open the bottom of the first two out
of 23 now
all four and sets it up for rizzo with
one out
rizzo got hit on 93.
sixth
hit by pitch
to lead the league and that
one stung
well the cubs have a scoring chance
first and second one away javier baez at
the plate bunted by baez a little
stumble by williams the throws gonna be
off the mark
here comes bryant he will score
and the cubs lead one to nothing
javi making it happen with a bunt and
then on the bases and it was kind of a
shock i did not anticipate javi trying
to bunt here with two men on and one out
but he does here's wilson contreras
he gets another strikeout
number six
his throw allows
an unearned run and there's some barking
going on here trevor williams after
striking out contreras
said
something williams appeared to have
words and then stallings was given the
what what was that hard to know exactly
what what started that what was going
down and wilson's a fiery guy
and the 3-2
swing and a missed strike three got him
on a curve ball newman strikes out
that's number three for darvish there's
josh bill
swing and a miss strike three
back-to-back case for darvish to start
the fourth he had back-to-back
strikeouts in the second this is just a
heater not just a heater a real good
heater
swing a little long and a little late
and the 2-2 from darvish the left-handed
batting moran will take strike three
called darvish strikes out the side
cubs won pirates nothing bottom of the
fourth inning here's jason kipnis kidnap
struck out leaving two men on back in
the second inning kipnis up in the air
to right way back there and it is goron
a home run
for chemnis
cubs lead two to nothing
his first homer as a cub
strikeout victim first time this time he
sits back on the breaking ball and
unloads the cops who lead two nothing
here in the fifth inning and trevor
williams out after four and two thirds
nick turley will come on a left-hander
for the pirates two on for contreras
looking to do some damage here with two
outs the 3-2
four walks in the inning the bases are
loaded for jason hayward
in the right for a basement here comes
brian
schwarber right behind him the throw to
third not in time it's four nothing
it's been a while since they pushed to
run across home plate
oh off the leg of darvish it deflects
right to bias
actually you pointed it
by it's like hey
i made that play for you a little exit
velo off the backside of darvish 95
miles per hour and probably 75 miles per
hour on the deflection right in the
wallet comes with a great great
opportunity here in the eighth they'd
love to get two or three runs at least
rizz up with the bases loaded nobody out
the 2-1 rizzo lines a base hit into left
center field this will drive in two
bryant goes to third on a single by
rizzo cubs lead six to one
here's the closer craig kimbrell this is
not a safe spot with his team now
leading by
five bill moran and reynolds for the
pirates
and bell hits it deep to right
and it's gone
and the home run ball bites kimbrell
again
six to two
moran
in the air to deep left
and half won't have room it's in the
basket in the well
back-to-back home runs against craig
kimbrell and how big does that two-run
single by anthony rizzo and the
eighth-inning look now